yeah won't you go quintile the yarn over
from Brazil not a frequent opponent and
I'm going with my king Cyprien shadow
the bad thing is that the best movie is
really transporting to the Kings Indian
but I guess that's not not clearly
that's not really part of this this week
maybe it is the King's engine is a king
site he and shadow but Knight f6 is just
the better move there are a number of
issues with that even taking on e5 is
not super comfortable but the an idea
three or 92 are them are the real issues
so that black has problems equalizing
and well okay in the Kings Indian also
like an some issues equalizing but it's
not as problematic okay so this might
get to something where black really has
a nice position
not compared to a sub Kings Indian
positions i might might be up moves here
in the Kings in you very often you have
to go night back okay so he wants to
wants to check me down on a triumph hmm
that's true check
yeah not so not so nice she takes on
this check there however however this is
really so bad that my did not that that
might become very ugly but ok let's
let's try that push-up h5 check I was
thinking cat king of 89 f7 Queenie 8 is
that sediment OS is totally totally
erotic ok let's let's try ok it's not
even reacting cool as you run so i'm
taking and play Queenie a grind just
grabbing the Bichette oops I didn't see
the move at all ok yeah this is why I
don't play this kind of opening so ok
you try something and you get get killed
yeah because it's just so not solid but
ok this is not a hold of the opening but
just my blunder ok maybe maybe I still
have some play here with Bishop f5
coming Bishop f5 ok what does he wants
to evacuate yeah via H form yeah but it
care it's not that's not that bad maybe
I can also let's start with that and now
I need to need the rook the rook on edge
aid so let's start with that move maybe
also covering d3 and then king of seven
book a jet this might still be
still be I mean not good but it's
something that that can be can be tried
so I take no can also take two times on
your phone I mean one I can do that 95 I
can just go to g8 and there's Bishop a
GF 6 threatened so that is not that
great actually check if you go with 96
psycho Bishop f6 he has to go back and
then I take it six that's why am I don't
know okay you want the draw really don't
don't think so
just ask him if he really wants once a
draw would be really f after i had
blundered age 7 he probably wants to
play for a win and justifiably so that's
never enough compensation objectively
can just with Luke age 8 and so on I can
yeah irritate him check okay
if he goes to be four can I avoid the
draw no okay at he avoids it now okay so
do i have to check its exit sir I
probably have gym and now night f5 maybe
that's interesting attending a form fear
airy form it was quite serious okay he's
covering that but I have to shove each
for now getting some material night
before is that to move I just take 94
Queenie form Queenie 493 Queen it's not
a good idea probably let's just take
that and now here for 93 and night c 2
that's annoying and i'm attacking e6 and
it's probably quite quite dissatisfied
with the cause of that because i was
playing it like a [ __ ] and now i'm
suddenly begin it um okay tix 96 yes
just for the dance a good good endgame
efore is a week pawn
yep let's see here and then I know I'm
not threatening f3 now I should go back
I should go here actually for Luke g3
that's much better and here threatening
efore end on d3 is losing a thread now
here that wins the pony at least if we
need the big sent upon check
up 4483 well would it turn around time
warning check white resigns yeah the
first part of it I really played
terribly but then somehow it wasn't that
clear that's that's hitting the whole
idea here is probably completely bonkers
I this this was my idea Queenie aid this
this might be might be good yeah because
I'm trapping that but I wasn't sure
about this move and here I probably am
in trouble huh I really don't have a
good move here this is the comp the comp
suggestion but that can never be good
right here check it's the engines main
line and and it's not good news no it's
terrible but Castle is not bad i mean
what what exactly am i playing okay I
took and I totally did not c 9 h 70 I'm
just blundering stuff him k but where
does it get get him check it's checking
and back and we had this and check he
tried to avoid it with this to be honest
I'm not sure how that this is so bad
Bishop d3 is actually also move double
attacking c4 and the rook now that's
quite quite interesting but ok let's
let's look at that is that a bad idea
playing for you for ok probably he can
just prevent it right like rugby one
yeah yeah okay that's not enough so that
means Bishop d3 was also better but team
he ran into this and now yeah this is
just a bad end game now because his pony
is so weak and I got in this provoking
here and from here I think yeah
computers on minus two which is quite
depressing you know Luke c1 didn't help
but how does he how does the defender
yeah I'm going in here attacking efore i
have f 3 as a possible movement that's
just not good black some structure is
just so much better and whites bishop is
enormously helpless justing yeah that
was very lucky after opening didn't
really it didn't really work out okay
well thanks for watching